jacques yves cousteau est le premier
homme poisson en avant dans dès 1943
moore il permet aux plongeurs de najib
librement sous la mer
cet ancien officier a pratiquement tous
créés et de l'océanographie
grâce à la caméra sous marine il révèle
le monde entier le monde du silence
aucune difficulté ne résiste à sa
formidable ovation
il aménage un ancien de lui pour
effectuer ses premiers voyages c'est la
qualité qu'on soit aussi la soucoupe
plongeant ou d'un stage en méditerranée
un laboratoire flottant
des scientifiques ont étudié pendant des
années le milieu marin le commandant
dont la fine silhouette devient célèbre
dans le monde entier a donnée à
l'écologie c'est la trouille d'être
reçus par les sur détails mais met en
garde contre les dangers qui menacent
notre planète
la surpopulation du nucléaire la
déforestation en 1972 en antarctique
les hommes de cousteau réaliste un
nouvel exploit nager sous la banquise en
1990 vous qu'on doive dire qu'un
moratoire de 50 ans soit décrétée sur
l'exploitation des ressources minérales
et continent blanc
exane est le commandant à cause l'idée
des droits des enfants l'obligation de
leur offrir un monde où la croissance
économique et social ne rentrera pas
l'environnement